Danya where are you going Albert Jana
you've been spending a lot of time with
her lately is she your girlfriend
dad can you make her stop that could but
I won't
also I can't I just want to know what's
going on in your life and if this girl
is someone special to you then she's
special to me come on Marion oh if it
helps I don't care
thank you
when you were teenagers you tell your
parents stuff well no why do you expect
him to cuz I'm fun really
want to come over
[Music]
my parents won't let me for cokes ain't
there oh but I guess I don't have to
tell them where you go
Oh out where Janice her parents gonna be
there yeah okay let me just call them
make sure Owens oh and that's your last
name right Owen might being so weird I'm
not being weird are you no good that was
being weird
don't call him why not why can't you
just trust me because I know that you're
lying
what no I'm not I heard you on the phone
with Jana you spied on me I didn't mean
to but I'm glad that I did because you
just lied to my face you are not going
anywhere
try and stop me you walk out that door
and your father gets involved
lead this dad you missed everything well
huh
Georgie lied the mom to be alone in
Jana's house but mom knew cuz she
listened it on his phone call boy
now he's grounded and everyone's mad not
me I'm super happy well bye dad the
University offered to pay for us to go
to California
they're even putting us up in a hotel
Tim we're going to California
no just me and Dad that's fair
I'm so happy for you sometimes sarcasm
was late on so thick even I could detect
it
Thanks this was not one of those times